quelques jours après avoir annoncé un
embargo sur les importations de pétrole
et de gaz russe et de nombreuses
sanctions économiques et financières
washington poursuit sur sa lancée et
intensifie ses sanctions contre moscou
objectif contribuer à mettre à genoux
l'économie russe et le financement de sa
guerre en ukraine
une mesure importante elle ouvre la voie
à l'imposition de tarifs douaniers
punitifs contre de nombreux produits
russes emporté les pays du g7 ont
emboîté le pas à washington
tout comme les européens réunis en
sommet à versailles les 27 sont apparus
plus uni que jamais pour maintenir la
pression sur moscou la question de la
dépendance énergétique de l'europe à la
russie a été placé en haut de l'agenda
des 27
la commission européenne veut réduire
des deux tiers dès cette année cette
dépendance de l'union au gaz russe et à
plus long terme bruxelles poursuit
l'objectif d'une indépendance
énergétique totale de l'union européenne
m
l'union européenne devrait annoncer de
nouvelles mesures ce samedi emmanuel
macron a prévenu à l'issue du sommet que
les européens étaient prêts à prendre
des sanctions massives contre la russie
si la guerre se poursuivre